so this week we are talking about exam
technique and the analogy which I like
to make when it comes to taking exams is
a spear trying to go through a shield
the shield represents the exam it
represents what's standing between you
and the grade that you want while the
spear is you and your revision efforts
and the spear is made of two parts first
of all there's the haft
which is the long stick like thing that
you hold onto and you thrust try to get
through the shield this represents your
revision effort it represents months
weeks of it's working hard sitting in
libraries and putting in the time doing
past papers learning your syllabus
incredibly important without it you
can't do well in the exam but there's
also the second part the second part of
the spear is the blade that's on top of
it and this represents your exam
technique if the blades rusty or blunt
then it doesn't matter how much force
you put into it it's not going to go
through that shield you're not going to
get the grade you want on the other hand
if your blade is very sharp you don't
need so much force to punch through to
the other side and this is your exam
technique being rusty or being
incredibly good and this video is all
about trying to get your exam technique
sharp as possible first of all make sure
you're aware of the format of your exam
this might sound a little bit trivial
and hopefully by the time you've done
lots and lots of passed papers it will
be trivial to you but make sure you're
aware of what the exam paper will look
like so to give you an example one of my
undergraduate exams I had to take was an
hour and a half long and it had a 14
mark section a which was short on to
questions and a 60 mark Section B where
I chose two questions out of the
possible three now knowing that meant
that I could go into the exam open the
paper and know what I expected I didn't
have to waste time in the exam coming up
with a plan I already knew what I was
going to do in addition to knowing what
the exam paper will look like it's
incredibly important to know what will
be on the exam paper I don't mean
knowing exactly what's gonna be in each
question I mean knowing what's on the
syllabus and what you can and cannot be
assessed on syllabuses are available
freely online for every example make
sure you find the right example for each
question for each exam that you're
taking but make sure you are aware of
what's expected of you and further to
that make sure you're aware of how you
are assessed so find mark schemes for
each of your exams that you're going to
be taking
know what's going to get your points and
what's considered irrelevant hopefully
all of this will be trivial to you if
you've done enough passed pickle
practice like we talked about in the
last video secondly it is incredibly
important to use time management to
divide your efforts on the exam paper
effectively so to go back to the exact
example which I had a undergraduate I
knew that the 40 marks section that I
had should take about half an hour and
the 60 marks section should take about
an hour and looking at the clock I had
to be strict on myself saying right well
that's the allocated time for this
section I've got to leave it now and go
on to the next section now it's not just
as simple as dividing up the number of
marks and allocating time based on the
percentage of marks on the paper and the
percentage of time that you have on the
total exam you should also allow
yourself a buffer at the end of the exam
to go through and check your answers and
to return to questions they had to leave
earlier now what that meant for me and
about Jack was I spent 20 minutes on the
first section and 40 or 50 minutes on
the second section and then have plenty
of time at the end to go back and finish
all the questions which I haven't quite
got this is where knowing the format of
your exam paper is very very important
and you can also use this in your
practice so you can do pass papers with
timed elements so you give yourself the
amount of time you would have in the
exam and then you're very strict on
yourself saying right I'm going to get
this section done by then or this essay
question done by this time and I have to
move on it's a very important skill to
develop thirdly it's incredibly
important to approach your exams and to
walk into the hall with a positive
mental attitude if you walk into an exam
thinking this isn't going to go very
well I'm probably going to fail it's not
going to go very well and you possibly
will fail regardless of how you might
feel about an exam you've got to go in
and convince yourself that it's going to
be okay now this might feel like lying
to yourself sometimes but this isn't the
same as being complacent about the exam
you've got to go in and think that you
can do it no use looking up at a
mountain and saying well never in a
climb that's way too high you've got to
at least try and having a positive
mental attitude commit you do things
that you wouldn't believe previously
you'd be able to do so believe in
yourself
because ultimately if you don't believe
in yourself then who will lastly for the
main points make sure you have all of
the equipment that you need to go into
the exam so in particular make sure you
have a clear plastic pencil case if
that's in your exam regulations and make
sure you have all the necessary pens
pencils protractors rulers calculator if
it's on the exam board and a water
bottle now you might not feel you need a
water bottle but I recommend taking one
just in case and make sure that conforms
with the exam regulations which in case
you can tell are quite important to
learn and make sure you know what is and
isn't allowed you don't to be stressing
about whether your pencil case or your
water bottle is going to cause your
problems on the day you just want to get
that sorted ahead of time so you can
just focus on doing well so make sure
you know the exam regulations and you
have everything prepared before you go
so those are the big rules which I
wanted to talk about there's also a few
things which I've learned from personal
experience which I think might be
helpful firstly when you sit down here
examine you're told you can open the
exam paper just do that open the exam
paper and read read every question
carefully I had a cousin who managed to
scupper one of her exams by instead of
writing an essay about a promise wrote
an essay about Primrose and these
mistakes happens make sure they don't
happen to you read every question
incredibly carefully if you're making a
choice between for example one answer
questions or essay questions make that
choice very carefully where all the
possible factors and don't rush we've
got plenty of time the exam gives you
more time than you need by quite a long
way so use that time make an informed
intelligent decision secondly at the end
of your exam in that time where you've
given yourself to go back to previous
questions if you have finished all those
questions and to be honest even if you
haven't finished everything go back and
check check everything check especially
in maths exams I found four mistakes
it's so easy to mistake a factor of two
or a factor of Pi or a minus sign and it
can completely ruin a question in fact
you'll often find your untended not so
you put yourself in so go back read
every question that you've written to
make sure you're perfectly
with it you can make changes right up
until they tell you to stop writing so
if you need to do thirdly and lastly
make sure you use the few minutes before
you go into the exam as effectively as
you can a lot of people I found when I
was taking exams would sort of cluster
around and they would be making
themselves stressed but worried by
talking to other people about our advice
for this much oh no I didn't do enough
what's the things going to come up it
can be incredibly distracting so as long
as you're not harming anyone else's
chances don't give a crap about anybody
else on what they're doing just do what
you need to do to do your best you can
be incredibly selfish just before you go
to exam like I said it's always not
harming anyone else's chances do what
you need to do and that can be sitting
in the corner reading through notes it
can be meditating it can be talking to
your friends just make sure that you are
doing what you want to do don't feel
pressured into doing something else it's
really the most important time arguably
just we go to the exam to really make
sure your blade is as sharp as possible
your mind as a sharp as possible and you
are going to do your absolute best so
that's what I have to say on exam
technique if you missed the video last
week I did one on exam preparation and
revision and hopefully by this point you
are really in the run of doing past
papers and you are getting yourself
ready for your exams all I can say is
best of luck to everybody who's doing
them and next week they'll just be a
quick video from me providing hopefully
a little bit of motivation and
encouraging you to keep pushing right to
the end thanks very much for watching
and if you found this video useful then
consider giving it a like or subscribe
to the channel and the very best of luck
with your exams